from calorie counter portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between pepsi in the uk and the us
this is food wars
[Music]
in the uk pepsi comes in a range of
portion sizes but these do vary slightly
depending on which type of pepsi you're
buying we used to be able to get mini
cans but they've been discontinued so
now you can get classic pepsi in four
portion sizes there's a 330 milliliter
can
there's a 500 milliliter bottle
there's a 1.5 liter bottle and as a
2-liter bottle in the u.s our pepsi
comes in these following sizes the mini
can is the smallest 7.5 fluid ounces
next one up the classic can 12 fluid
ounces then move up to plastic bottles
this one is 16.9 fluid ounces and then
we got the 20 fluid ounce bottle and if
that's not enough we go up to one liter
bottle literal cola then moving up a
little more
1.25 liter bottle and then our biggest
bottle is the two liter bottle we can
also get glass bottles but like the
classic can they are 12 ounces
[Music]
where regular pepsi is concerned both
countries cap out at a two liter bottle
however in the uk we can go one step
further when it comes to diet and max
pepsi certain retailers such as iceland
or b m stock these
[Music]
a three liter bottle of pepsi max or
pepsi diet we finally have something
bigger than america we did it i don't
know if that's a good or a bad thing
probably bad for the sort of nation's
health but you know nice to be different
for once there are some other slight
size differences for the sugar and
sugar-free options in the uk as well for
example in the uk we can get a 1.25
litre bottle of pepsi max or pepsi diet
which we can't get the classic pepsi the
size differences are largely down to the
uk's sugar tax it's attacks which raise
the price of drinks with more than five
grams of sugar per 100 milliliters the
higher prices reduce the demand for the
full sugar versions of soft drinks
making it less viable to sell them in
large containers such as the three liter
but don't worry because you can still
get sugary pepsi in bulk quantities our
largest bulk is the 36 can pack of pepsi
and that's the 12 ounce cans that is 432
fluid ounces of soda or 3.375 gallons of
pepsi now that pack of cans is at least
available at sam's club possibly costco
i don't know but i went to sam's club
and unfortunately they would not let me
buy it without a membership so the best
i could do are these pictures of me with
the pants
that is much larger than our largest
option which is this a 24 pack of cans
not only is our multipack only two
thirds the size of the american one but
the cans themselves were also smaller a
can in the uk contains 330 milliliters
while a can in the us contains 355. this
means that the total for our 24 pack
comes to 2.09 gallons even if we had a
36 pack it would still be smaller than
the american version we need three extra
cans to make up the difference
here are all the pepsi products you'll
find in the uk that you won't find in
the us
here are all the pepsi products from the
u.s you won't find in the uk we'll start
with the exclusive flavors of pepsi in
the uk we have pepsi max raspberry
it's got that really comforting like
extremely nostalgic artificial blue
raspberry flavor that you're used to
on pepsi's uk website it also said they
do lime pepsi but i wasn't able to find
that at any of the stores i tried
we have a few exclusive pepsi options of
our own starting down here we have pepsi
real sugar which is in fact made with
real sugar not the high fructose corn
syrup stuff
not bad
we also have pepsi mango and pepsi mango
zero sugar seems like a weird fruit
choice whoa smells good
i'm surprised by how good this is and i
got the mango zero sugar
oh already smells drastically different
it's got a real chemically aftertaste
not as good as a regular this one here
is
pepsi soda shop cream soda
very nice and the last one
pepsi vanilla
i'm gonna be honest with you pepsi could
use a lot more vanilla it's like vanilla
kissed
there it is all right right now what i
want to do is compare the already tasted
real sugar pepsi to the regular pepsi
which has high fructose corn syrup
regular pepsi
um pepsi is like
harsher than coke
yeah
but to say something somewhat
controversial but bring it i want all
the smoke real sugar pepsi
tastes just like coke
it's just smoother
this is like
yeah this is like harsher
joe's kind of have to send me some
american pepsi as well as some real
sugar pepsi so i'm going to do a
three-way taste test and see if i can
tell the difference
pepsi number one
that's very like
strong flavor
quite like a syrupy texture to it almost
pepsi number two
yeah very sweet but almost in a more
gentle kind of way
and the number three
more similar in kind of like i'd say
sweetness and mouth feel to the middle
one this one is the one that stood out
with the strongest taste in my opinion
these two were very similar which is
making me think that these are the
british and real sugar pepsis i'm not
sure in which order but they had a more
gentle taste whereas this one seemed
harsher and tasted very syrupy so i'm
gonna guess british
american real sugar
american normal pepsi
i'm shocked
these two tasted really similar to me
and this one stood out like i said
and it wasn't particularly pleasant
maybe the uk needs to take a leaf out of
america's book and just put high
fructose corn syrup in everything the
other exclusive pepsi item in the uk is
this pepsi sodastream syrup for the
uninitiated a sodastream is a device
which lets you carbonate your own drinks
at home now as a sparkling water
obsessive i actually own one of these
so we're gonna make our own pepsi so
what you do is you get one of your
little sodastream bottles
fill it to the first line and attach it
to the machine
then you press this button and the magic
happens
[Music]
according to this bottle you add about
half a cup of the syrup to this
that's quite cool
the first thing i get is just pepsi it
tastes a lot like pepsi max there is a
slightly unpleasant aftertaste which i'm
not sure where that's come from maybe i
used too much syrup who knows but i
think yeah in terms of recreating a food
drink at home with like not a lot of
equipment it's pretty good
and that's pretty much it as far as
pepsi excludes stuff concerned but we're
not stopping there pepsico owns more
beverage brands but it does differ
depending on which country you live in
now while in the u.s keurig dr pepper
owns 7up in the uk it's actually owned
by pepsico which means that technically
all of these are pepsi exclusives
british 7up comes in four forms as
classic seven up
a seven up three seven up cherry free
and as a sodastream syrup
that's actually not bad it doesn't have
the unpleasant aftertaste that the pepsi
one did that to me just tastes like
seven up one other thing that's worth
pointing out is that in the uk this is
considered lemonade like if you walk
into a pub or a restaurant and ask for a
glass of lemonade this is what you'll
get like a clear sparkling beverage is
that not the case in america that is
definitely not lemonade and it is super
weird
lemonade is like lemon
not juice
right but you squeeze lemons and water
and mix it up
and it's like more refreshing and kind
of tart it's closer to a lemon juice
that it's definitely not carbonated in
front of me we have something that's
brand new and it is called pepsi nitro
what is it wait excuse me nitro pepsi
flip up looks to be a tall boy
of pepsi that according to the can is
nitrogen infused cola with smaller
bubbles and a smoother taste
did you hear that oh man
that's a pretty hard pour right
oh it's not going crazy like a normal
pepsi would right i'm more excited about
the vanilla let's get let's really get
really good audio on this one already
hard pour
yeah it's a little bit smoother
but still tastes just like pepsi and
that is like carbonated which is fine
do the vanilla
much better ooh that's nice
yeah the issue i'm having with it is
that the only time
soda is that smooth is when it's flat
up with it
but
it's just okay pepsi has a few exclusive
brands in the us including mug root beer
sierra mist and bubbly their carbonated
water brand
my group here
i was the master
at being able to tell different
root beers on taste i could tell them
apart
that information is like in my dna one
of these days we'll do like uh we'll do
like a root beer lineup or taste test i
guarantee i'll ace that test
yeah it's taking me back
also they got serum mist i hate serum
mist it's a lemon lime flavor i don't
know if they're competing with sprite or
7up i always hated this
sprite is better 7up is better serum
serums taste the way like fruit flavored
shampoo smells if that makes sense
[Music]
okay and this will be
my ranking system from best to worst so
first we're going to go strawberry
no i do not like that cherry
i think these all might be bad
that one's a little better than the
strawberry but
pineapple nope woof
grapefruit
low expectations on this one
oh my god it smells like an armpit oh
man if i went into a public restroom and
smell like this i would run out
no
oh
yeah that's the worst one lime can't
scrub lime come on
congratulations you're the least
defensive
peach
what the hell happened why are these all
so bad
raspberry
[Music]
oh man the smell of that
it says natural flavor it does not taste
natural at all at all at all ah
blackberry
okay that's the best one but it's not
very good
and last and that mango okay so we had
the mango so they know how to flavor
things mango properly the mango peps is
fantastic
i mean yeah these these two are like the
best woman ever again bubbly's not very
good
how could they screw these up this bad
pepsico also owns mountain dew in the uk
and the us but that is a story for
another episode
[Music]
story time anyone ever remember or heard
of new coke well you can thank pepsi for
that once upon a time coca-cola was
actually losing market share and pepsi
put out a very popular ad campaign where
people were blind taste testing coke and
pepsi and picking pepsi so coke panicked
and they pushed the market a beverage
called new coke which is basically coke
that's supposed to taste more like pepsi
guess what a huge marketing blunder not
only did coca-cola fans get annoyed that
they changed the formula of a beverage
they liked but all new coke was doing
was giving pepsi more attention either
way just 79 days after introducing new
coke coke announced that they'd be
bringing back the original drink called
coca-cola classic and you would maybe
notice like 20 years coca-cola was
called coca-cola classic a classic on
there have you ever wondered why that's
because they want to make it perfectly
clear this is not that new coke that you
hated from 1988 or whatever so pepsi
they had their day in the sun but to be
honest i mean coke is included more
dominant brand speaking of product
failures remember crystal pepsi that was
widely considered to be one of the
biggest product failures ever time
magazine put crystal pepsi at number
three on the biggest fails list thrillas
called it soda world's greatest fail but
why soda sales were stagnant in the
early 90s with consumers instead opting
for clear and caffeine-free sodas former
pepsi marketing exec david novak pitched
a drink that was both and crystal pepsi
was born the recipe was developed by
food scientist surinder kumar and pepsi
ended up with a clear drink that
maintained an almost identical taste to
classic pepsi they rushed it out in time
for the 1993 super bowl it was backed by
a 40 million dollar ad campaign and they
did sell about half a billion dollars
worth of it but by march of 93 the hype
quickly faded consumers did not love the
new flavor and the concept was even
parodied by snl in a crystal gravy
sketch hilarious roughly one year after
launch crystal pepsi was discontinued
but if you never got the chance to try
it there's still hope for you pepsi is
bringing crystal pepsi back for a
limited time to celebrate its 30th
anniversary you can't buy it in stores
but you can't enter a contest by sending
them a picture of yourself from the 90s
on twitter here is my entry
i've got a story of my own remember that
time when pepsi briefly became the
world's sixth most powerful military
force it all started in 1959 at the
american national exhibition in moscow
when a discussion between the then vice
president richard nixon and nikita
khrushchev became heated a pepsi exec
called donald kendall stepped in to hand
kristjev a glass of pepsi to cool him
down chris chev enjoyed pepsi so much
that arrangements were made for it to be
imported from the us to russia as part
of the deal pepsi even negotiated a
monopoly locking coca-cola out of the
country the drink's popularity exploded
in an otherwise uncontested market but
there was one problem payment the
russian ruble wasn't accepted outside of
the soviet union so the russians had to
come up with an alternative arrangement
they settled on a universal currency
vodka russia traded thousands of cases
of stolich nia vodka for pepsi syrup
throughout the 60s and the 70s however
they did run into problems in the 80s
pepsi's popularity in russia combined
with a boycott due to the soviet afghan
war meant that vodka just wasn't going
to cut it anymore here's where things
get fun in the spring of 1989 pepsi and
the soviet union agreed a deal whereby
pepsi would be given 17 old submarines
and three warships they would then sell
them for scrap to pay for the pepsi
therefore for a short period of time
pepsi controlled the sixth most powerful
navy in the world now that is a food war
here's everything in a pepsi in the u.s
carbonated water high fructose corn
syrup caramel color sugar phosphoric
acid caffeine citric acid natural
flavors here's everything in pepsi in
the uk
carbonated water sugar color caramel
e150d phosphoric acid and flavorings
including caffeine now obviously pepsi
won't go into specifics on the
flavourings used because the recipe is a
closely guarded secret
or is it pepsi was invented in north
carolina in 1893 by a man named caleb
bradham first is called brad's drink but
then renamed the pepsi in 1898. it comes
from the fact that it was marketed as
relieving dyspepsia another word for
indigestion
it's giving me indigestion so that's
weird however in 1923 the original pepsi
cola company went bankrupt due to
fluctuating sugar prices after world war
one as part of the bankruptcy filing
bradham had to release the recipe for
pepsi as it was accompanied asa and it's
still publicly available to this day so
you can make your own pepsi at home
simply by combining sugar water caramel
color lime juice phosphoric acid alcohol
lemon juice orange juice cinnamon oil
nutmeg collander cilantro and peptide
which is an essential oil extracted from
the leaves and twigs of bitter orange
trees yeah just those things
the rights to pepsi were eventually
bought by a man named charles gupp who
was then the president of the loft
corporation which later merged into
pepsico they of course claimed that they
reformulated the recipe after the
takeover but the original is still there
for all to see
enough with the history lesson what is
the difference between us and uk pepsi
that is why we are here first let's talk
about acids both the uk and the us
acidify their pepsi with phosphoric acid
it's a weak acid which is primarily used
as a fertilizer when added to foods it
provides a tangy taste but it's also
been linked to causing kidney stones as
well as osteoporosis the us also uses
citric acid in its pepsi citric acid is
more common and generally safer
acidifier in foods but
it's one of the things in sodas that
will cause tooth enamel to erode after
repeated consumption i happen to have
some of that right here
[Music]
that's sour
another major difference in pepsi is
that in the us we sweeten our pepsi with
high fructose corn syrup in addition to
sugar high fructose corn soapers
everywhere in american sodas and candies
government subsidies make it super cheap
for american farmers to grow corn and
food manufacturers use corn syrup to
save money instead of importing sugar
came from places like mexico and brazil
corn syrup is hard to find at all in the
uk we did manage to track down this
small bottle but only in a specialist
grocery store even then it's just
regular corn syrup and not high fructose
the good news is that it isn't actually
any worse for you than sugar the main
impact is on the taste which explains
why we have a pepsi made with real sugar
here it is a version of the u.s drink
which does not contain any corn syrup
this version actually has the exact same
ingredients as the uk pepsi anything
else to note well our old friend caramel
color is back in the uk it's listed as
caramel e150d while the us just lists
caramel color this is a somewhat
controversial food coloring used to give
things like pepsi a distinctive golden
brown tinge there are four classes of
caramel color classes one through four
studies have suggested that the
production of classes three and four
create a byproduct that may put people
at risk of developing cancer of course
why can't we enjoy anything
well the fda has stopped short of
banning caramel color the state of
california added to its proposition 65
list of chemicals known to cause cancer
and birth defects or reproductive harm
are these potentially harmful caramel
colors in our pepsi well in the uk the
answer is yes we know that class 4
caramel color is used in the uk because
sulfite ammonia caramel has the e-number
e150d which is on the list what about
the us where it just says caramel color
without specifics we reached out to
pepsi to ask which class they use over
here and their answer was nothing they
said they would not comment on the
specific ingredients due to proprietary
issues yeah guys you're afraid that
detail is going to really help
cut into your competition so your pepsi
may or may not be putting you at risk of
cancer so glad we cleared that up
in the u.s a can of pepsi contains the
following 150 calories zero grams of fat
41 grams of carbohydrates and all those
are sugars and 30 milligrams of sodium
a can of pepsi in the uk contains the
following 135 calories zero grams of fat
36 grams of carbs of which 36 grams are
sugars and four milligrams of sodium
obviously the alarming stat here is the
sugar just one can of us pepsi contains
80 of your daily sugar allowance really
one
the uk statistic is slightly better at
just 72 percent of your daily allowance
but that is still a lot of sugar in a
relatively small amount of liquid
there's also some caffeine and pepsi a
12 ounce can contains 38 milligrams of
caffeine which is about half as much of
an eight ounce cup of coffee i of course
am drinking both pepsi and coffee at the
same time
pepsi doesn't openly disclose its
caffeine content in the uk but according
to a website i found called
caffeineinformer.com a can of uk pepsi
max contains 42 milligrams of caffeine
the us equivalent of pepsi max is pepsi
zero sugar but a can not pictured here
has over 69 milligrams of caffeine
making it significantly more caffeinated
than the uk version but the good news
according to the fda you need to consume
1200 milligrams of caffeine in a short
period of time to put your health in
danger that's about 18 cans of pepsi
zero sugar i like a challenge let's go
uh can i drink
a carbonated water without burping
wait ah damn it i'm sorry
i tried